welcome to this video I'm playing town
tavern from the UK the name of that's
chicken no I am with almost 2,400 yeah
my rating really has has suffered but
I'm just not in good shape at the moment
giving away many many a good positions
to draw us all universes so we have a
part of it should be 5s but uncommon
usually they they all go to be three
it's a more aggressively posted on v3
actually 2.8 f7 okay but there it's not
not too terrible move to put it on b5 of
course okay is giving up the bushing pal
but of course um I have a read porn on
c6 some compensation
yes still it should be quite quite
playable for Black Knight c4 maybe we
aren't world attacking b2 and
potentially grabbing uh-huh
yeah well maybe maybe he's playing for
95 I know yeah I really thought that b3
is a move you don't want to play because
of this diagonal with c5 potential idea
or not one idea five
okay so knight c6 mmm
Queen B 6 there's a 94
here this Bishop f4
okay this is all so i can just take a
Nazi six wow what the heck am i doing at
the moment unbelievable yeah I'm just
blundering material
yeah we can actually think about taking
e7 and d5 but i justjust take p8 it's a
it's the right one and now maybe Bishop
f4 hacking this night off
you know the only thing in my favors
that d 4 is really really a weakness the
spawn if I would manage to actually win
it there's some some hope but difficult
to accomplish you can always play the
Sam
yeah bit of a shame I really think I
hadn't had a quite promising position
out of the opening not two not an answer
or something but it was a very decent
position for the black pieces okay it's
still not completely easy win I've got a
good night and so on the bishop is
controlling the important c 1 square so
that his rooks are not so active
maybe if he's not careful I can take on
default at some moment on something like
that
is this a texty form maybe he saw it
quint here
yeah it's not so easy technique from
technical point of view for for white I
really just blundered the exchange
Bishop age six winning winning it back
hmm interesting
yeah it's debatable move behave he's
getting before and now adjourn is also
weakness anyway I'm going for Quincy for
Quincy one trying to invade
yo probably this was a bad idea playing
the a pawn
it's very tricky to to make any progress
in this position some check okay he's
trying something going for g-form oops
my ideas 96th reform
yeah ok I want to I want to threaten
this and if he takes the pawn on before
one's hanging if it covers it I have
grouped see a 20 or C 1 you're doing for
counter play I wants to get it running
quickly ok I need to be need to be quick
takes Queen takes this yeah okay the
pond
oopsie for coming
yeah why this should probably win but
check it still storage tricky position
I need some way to enter the position
here cannot believe it Quincy 7
something to see to the check check
Quinn have one mate Oh made checkmate no
while Jarrod's was just just very lucky
starting with this this exchange blunder
and everything I mean yeah well I need
to lucky break once in a while but what
the heck I just I just I just blundered
the exchange for absolutely nothing and
I can play just whatever look see a door
with a normal position I mean I like
like because I'm just one of those guys
once they have two bishops but it's
probably just equal and this is mean it
just just like that I really I thought
Bishop f4 he and I think this is better
really hacking hacking the light off but
because this Bishop is not great but
okay what he played is perfectly all
right i mean this bishop on c5 protects
d 4 and so on he may be needs to play g4
at the appropriate moment may be here
yeah yeah this is this is the right way
to play it cannot I can't go back but
then you just take it and if i push I
mean Queen g3 or maybe even that one
yeah this is no compensation the night
it is a bit off side I needed to do
something so after each for it it still
is good for white but not so ur self
evident how to win he basically just
kept the position as it is until he
blundered the exchange back ID i think
it's probably equal but after that why
does so better again he's got the palm
now i'm struggling him really struggling
maybe I should take on before him suck
the exchange back yeah it's probably a
good idea check HERE around around here
white should win but it sir it's tricky
i kept pausing slight problems okay here
black wins with Roxy to Jack and now
queen e 6 is the winner Wow I don't
really understand why okay this is a
text ah wow yeah this is really a
computer chess on g4s queen d 6 with a
double attack threatening mate and
threatening the book is this kind of
stuff is incredibly incredibly difficult
to find with a little time I mean it was
clear that I needed to to enter the
position somehow but I didn't really
find a way black gets better chat as
well but not not winning I don't know
it's winning this is in fact a winner
already yeah well I was suspicious that
there should be something at least after
this I can i can get the pawn this is
what i thought he should do it's not
easy to cover him on the phone and he
ran into champney immediate made yeah
just a bad game but chose you can always
find even in in lost or bad positions
thanks for watching